So the Rocket Project at UCLA is an
aerospace engineering club on campus
we have about 120 undergraduate members at
the moment and we compete at a variety
of rocket competitions across America. I
think it's definitely a place where we
have students with a drive unlike any
other.
We've been working with schools and
setting up outreach visits where we
visit classrooms and we really try to
inspire students.
So Bruin Partners is a student initiated student-led
organization. Students from all
backgrounds at UCLA volunteer mentoring
both middle and high schoolers.
This partnership that we've been able to make
between Rocket Project and Bruin
Partners has has been a great way that
we can bring that project-based learning
to the next level.
We've worked with the Lux
Lab on campus which has been 3D printing
components for us and we've put together
some modular rocket kits for them that
the kids will be able to put together
and then actually launch.
We're gonna be going through the three main components of the rocket which we've
3D printed out here. The nose cone which is the upper section that sort of breaks the wind for
the rocket and they fuselage or the body
which is the main section, the
cylindrical portion, and then the fins.
The fundamentals are the exact same as
any aerospace engineer would need we
want to make it clear to them that
anything is possible and they can also
become rocket scientists.
This is our test rocket. The launch was
completely successful.
(You want to actually grab the one right next to it?)
(Perfect, we'll come by right now.)
We're all part of the Rocket Project at UCLA. We are an aerospace engineering
undergraduate group. So we're basically a club.
There's... there's many disparities in education
we work towards getting rid of those
disparities.
I love engineering, I love rockets,
who doesn't like controlled explosions, right?
But also while I'm here and I have
the time I really wanted to give back to
the community.
The outreach really fits with the Rocket Project's vision for the future.
Sharing that excitement that we
have with the next generation that's
going to be taking our place and
exploring and really doing some amazing things.
The biggest impact we
have is really just kind of showing them
that engineering and problem-solving can
be exciting.
(Three... two... one...)
Yeah
Us coming in and saying hey look how fun it can be and
showing off some of the work we've done and
sharing our college experiences is
really valuable for the students.
I thought it was pretty cool that we got
to see real rockets in action.
- How did your rocket do?
Amazing
You're never gonna be able to do something perfect the first time...
and being able to
continually improve and develop and get
to a product that makes you happy and
satisfies you is a great thing that you
can do in engineering and I'm really
excited to continue with the program
making it better and ultimately seeing
these kids grow up and be the best that
they can be so...
Makes me happy.
...Ohhhh! It was a success!